russell wilson and sierra are out with a
new retail concept
the house of lrnc which they co-founded
along with christine day
the former ceo of lululemon it's bigger
than just
us it's really it's really about this
idea of the house of love respect and
care
we really you know loved fashion both of
us and i was learning more about it and
she
she was already mastering it and so the
thought process was really
it'd be really cool to build this house
of fashion this idea of it so
as we've gone along the past couple
years you know obviously christine has
been a friend
of ours for a long time six six plus
years
it's an interesting time to launch a new
retail brand considering we're still on
the throws of the pandemic
with the retail sector being hit hard
with store closures bankruptcies
and supply chain issues across the globe
that being said
athleisure makes a lot of sense right
now as we continue to work from home
and people want to wear clothes that
they're comfortable in
from the business side several things
stood out to me for one
this wasn't just another celebrity
partnership
russell and sierra actually want to
build a business
and co-founded it alongside christine
day who helped build starbucks from the
ground up for over 20 years
and then ran lululemon for six years
during the financial crisis
to create a brand at a time like this
that
actually does something about it and
give hope to those younger generations
is really i think um you know very
satisfying for us and showing them that
the future they dream of can be real
that's really what we're what we're
working on it's not perfect
um you know the world isn't perfect and
you have to come up with solutions that
transition
um but and so that's what we're focused
on is finding that path
i never forget christine came out this
you know san diego we kind of sat down
at breakfast and we started talking
about you know she really loved this
idea let's
go for it let's build this out and let's
do this and
as we talked about it she was like you
know this is this is the thing that i
you know i really want to make a
difference you know this
albus have done lulu i've done starbucks
i've done all these major things and
and i think this has a chance to be just
as just as big in terms of you know
impact and everything else and so
let's go do it as we talked about that
we talked about the things that really
mattered to us
i think the things that set um human
nation and house of lrnc
apart are the really strict standards
that we've set around
sustainability and doing good the house
of
lrnc has a goal of democratizing fashion
which has been a traditionally exclusive
industry and making it more accessible
especially to young consumers the same
amount of love that we have for fashion
is the same amount of love we have to
make a difference and so um
you know it it's um it's super super
beautiful
to start with the values of love respect
and care you know and having that it
talked about the idea of democratizing
fashion and
being able to build you know build it
you know with and for the community and
uh you know and just doing things for
good they also launched the company as a
public benefits corporation
and b corp which means that they're
committed to the united nations
sustainability goals
in addition to that three percent of the
proceeds go to
their why not you foundation which is a
non-profit dedicated towards children's
education and health
as well as fighting poverty good man
brand um in its four years has already
donated over a million dollars to the
why not youth foundation
so that's certainly aspirational for the
other brands that we're creating
starting with human nation and then the
women's
line that will drop next summer i will
say that both he and i share the same
uh belief and kind of philosophy and
approach to life which is why not you
like why not you be able to go and do
everything that
you believe you can be your you know you
dream of why not you
everything that you need to thrive and
uh is within you
we've had dreams we still dream we still
have goals we still have goals we want
to meet and goals that we've checked off
the box
and i think that you know when i was a
young kid trying to you know make it an
nfl and trying to have all these dreams
and
it was a driving force question why not
why not me why not you
and that's why we created our foundation
wanted you foundation so for us
um we we we understand it very very
clearly
this is so much more than just a product
endorsement
you know this is actually building a
company that means something this isn't
just a collection
and it goes it goes all the way deep to
the ethos and purpose
of the company and and that's what um
you know russ and fear up for for
learning and building
um and so much deeper and and i think
that's
a really special story just in and of
itself
you